When my phone dies, I like to be tactful;
I prefer to say that it “passed away”.
Hey there power hungry people, I’m Jules
here for DNews.
Smartphone batteries suck.
Actually, all commercial batteries suck, and
that’s kind of a big problem.
Every new smartphone iteration seems to have
twice the megapixels, three times the storage
space, no headphone jack, and… barely better
battery life.
And that battery life isn’t even guaranteed.
On an average smartphone, the lithium-ion
battery is generally expected to last between
300 and 500 charge cycles, and many of us
do go through an entire charge cycle every
single day.
So the fact is, smartphone batteries aren’t
really meant to stay fully functional for
more than a year.
The problem comes from the fact that since
the late 1970s, there hasn’t really been
a revolutionary commercial breakthrough in
battery technology.
Nearly all rechargeable modern batteries work
by creating electrical current from the movement
of lithium ions between electrodes, and for
this purpose, lithium is amazing.
It’s the least dense metal and has the highest
energy-to-weight ratio of comparable metals.
So when we made the shift from chunks of lead
floating in acid to slick smooth lithium as
a source of storable energy, batteries became
portable and lightweight.
It was an amazing breakthrough and changed
consumer electronics irrevocably… but that
was 30 years ago.
Today, we still use those same batteries.
But that’s not to say that battery life
isn’t getting better, sometimes in unexpected
ways.
Just this year, the iPhone 7 Plus came out
with about an hour more battery life than
the iPhone 6S Plus.
But the battery capacity is only a tiny bit
larger.
The trick is that what we consider “battery
life” is actually capacity, divided by consumption,
and while capacity is stagnant, power consumption
is not.
The new iPhone processor chip uses only two-thirds
as much power as the previous iteration, while
reportedly increasing performance by 40%.
Basically, the less power your phone uses,
the better its battery life, without making
any substantial changes to the battery itself.
Every year, computers and smartphones are
able to do more with less.
But that doesn’t quite solve the bigger
problem: batteries wear out and become useless
pretty quickly.
According to Apple, on their Macbooks, after
about 1000 cycles, you’re left with only
about 80% of the battery’s original capacity,
maybe less, and it only gets worse from there.
To solve this seemingly unavoidable issue,
researchers from University of California,
Irvine accidentally invented a battery that
never dies.
Well, seemingly never.
Apparently, a doctoral candidate in their
research lab was fooling around, and as we
all do for fun, she coated a set of gold nanowires
in manganese dioxide, and then sealed them
in an electrolyte gel.
Hahaha, oh those scamps!
Manganese!
The trick is that nanowires conduct electricity
very very well and have a large surface area
to store and transfer electrons.
But these wires are also SUPER fragile, and
they tend to break down after use.
But coating the wires seems to have solved
this major problem.
In the lab, this mini-battery went on to experience
200,000 charge cycles.
That's roughly 500 times more than the expected
optimal lifecycle of a lithium-ion battery,
while still operating between 94 and 96 percent
efficiency.
Even after three months, the normally super-fragile
wires were still fully functional thanks to
their gel coating.
Although its in the early research stage,
researchers think this battery could last
up to 400 years.
But your smartphone is still gonna die in
a few years and that's because it's still
using technology from the 1970s.
It's optimized, but obsolete.
A number of tech groups have developed small
scale solutions, a combination of which may
prove to be the next big battery breakthrough,
but as for now, most solutions are impractical
due to cost, longevity, and most importantly;
safety.
New batteries need to be tested for a long
time before they’re introduced on the market.
Just look at the Note 7.
For now, it looks like battery life will continue
to suck.
If you’re into finding out what makes things
tick, like what’s in your electronics, you’re
probably like me and love the show How It’s
Made.
Now you can watch this and other Science Channel
shows on the Science Go App!
Check it out and download for free at your
App Store.
And if you want to know more how different
types of batteries work in more detail, Trace
has a video all about that here!
Is battery life your biggest phone complaint?
What other phone improvements do you want
to see?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe for more
videos everyday.